let's circle back sure circle back we're
going to circle back
to uh the covid lockdowns in this
business and the economy
because we have this story that i find
particularly interesting now in the
previous segment we're talking about a
business
that accrued four hundred thousand
dollars in fines over violating these
covert restrictions
now with the with the vaccine mandates
that that are popping up well for the
most
with private businesses and now in new
york from a public uh uh from a public
place
we got the story from timcast.com
boston's democrat mayor compares
vaccine passports to papers required
during slavery and jim crow
interesting that's bold uh democrat
boston mayor kim jane has compared
vaccine passports to the papers required
slavery and jim crow the first black
person to serve as mayor of the city
also compared vaccine passports to
demands that former president obama show
his birth certificate
during the birtherism scandal i mean
this is this is uh i agree i'm i
i'm not gonna uh pretend to know about
you know these these
horrible things throughout history but
what i say i agree is that
it is an overbearing demand from the
state on regular people
to implement these things to the extent
that you can't go to a store you can't
go to a bar
you can't go to a music venue or
something now in new york i don't think
they're saying
i think you can go to stores still
they're saying indoor activities
but as far as i'm concerned if you
mandate a vaccine for
one thing let's say they were like you
need a vaccine to go to uh the hot dog
stand on 7th street
you've mandated vaccines it's over as
far as i'm concerned
because you've you've you've hit at a
core function for many people i don't
care who or
how many so when they say if you want to
go out to eat you need
you need to have your vaccine and
vaccine card new york is mandated
vaccines period there's
no other reason to argue about it that's
wrong we saw that with the offspring
drummer pete i think pete pratt is his
name
he's got uh guillain-barre syndrome is
that i think so
uh and so he couldn't get it he couldn't
get the vaccine and now he's kicked out
of the band
is that what we're gonna create we're
gonna create this medical medical
segregation
is he actually kicked out of the band
yes that's insanity yeah
what he went to the doctor he has he had
a young age he developed a
guillain-barre syndrome which is
it's it's an extremely rare side effect
for people uh when they get some
vaccines and there's
it emerges for other reasons too but it
can be a side effect it is a side effect
of the johnson and johnson vaccine
and there are many doctors who advise
against hitting the vaccine if you have
this
syndrome which he did out of the band
you're gone insanity don't we have
violations of like the americans with
disabilities act
can't we be like if you are experiencing
this and is limiting to you like we we
we
we protect you in that regard well i
think at this point it becomes very
clear that it's all about having you
bend the knee if anyone was unaware um
if a person is disabled and has a very
good medical reason
for not getting vaccinated and your
response is to kick them out because
they haven't taken your preferred route
for handling this situation
it's obvious that what you're interested
in is submission
let me pull the story we have from the
daily mail more than half of
unvaccinated americans believe covet 19
shots are more dangerous than the virus
itself
paul finds over half of unvaccinated
americans 53
believe that cover 19 vaccines pose a a
higher health risk than the virus itself
the view is especially prominent among
americans who say they're definitely not
getting the vaccine with 75
believing the vaccine is more dangerous
in fact the virus is far more dangerous
out of 243 000 americans who died of
covet since january 2021
only 1 300 have been unvaccinated
still the indian delta variant is
persuading some to get their shots with
22 percent of unvaccinated respondents
saying the variant
was a vaccination motivator i don't know
the the full percentage numbers
but um yeah the the the virus is far
more dangerous well you said died from
covet right you read that that phrase
from covid
uh died of kophen of covet how many how
many people have died of covid oh
let's see out of 243 000 americans who
have died since january 2021
only 1 300 have been unvaccinated so
wait what 200 that's not correct i don't
know these numbers but they're saying
that 230 000 people died
of covid i've seen reports that people
had coveted in their system and died of
a motorcycle accident or some other
thing
with kovid they died with covid not
necessarily
of kovid but that there was no that's
not that's wrong that's wrong
they wrote the story wrong the story
it's it's they did it wrong
out of 243 000 kova debts deaths later
on they fix it
only 1 300 have occurred in vaccinated
americans
the top said have been unvaccinated as
if to imply
the vaccine was more dangerous that's
that's uh
so uh daily mail get it get it get a get
get an editor i'm nervous when people
say that we're in lockdowns because
we're in shutdowns and i'm nervous when
people say
that people died of covid when they died
with a co-morbidity we're not
with one of them right now ian well over
the last year in 2020 we had gone
through periods of shutdown and i heard
people say locked down locked
they like that word that button it's a
but there were lots of instances of
shutdown that people were calling
lockdown let's not make it worse than it
see we don't have to make it seem worse
than it is
the same way
it's freight we're phrasing it's it's
subtle little language twist that people
do to control this narrative right now
you're saying to tell people to to to
accept that they're barred from leaving
their homes or going to their jobs
no but i'm saying if that's a lockdown
if there's if an area gets shut down
don't say that it's locked down by like
lock and key
just it's just oh businesses aren't open
that doesn't mean you can't walk around
outside
so it's not a lockdown system right yeah
that's called apologizing
for authoritarianism no if we say that
we have lockdowns and we keep saying it
then the government will put them into
place and people will passively let it
happen because they're used to
lockdowns we had shutdowns for the most
part united states we had maybe had a
few instances of
things being locked down but for the
most part the united states was very
leniently
shut down as opposed to australia
massively locked down like you're saying
you're you're drawing where are you
drawing the line
where the police don't let people go
outside i mean they're arresting people
for walking around
that happened in the u.s very very
rarely though for the most part
we had lockdowns there were some
instances of it it was very rare and
i argue it violates the constitution
it's semantics it's it's
shut down lockdown what's the difference
it's because if if you tell people that
we're locked down for
all of 2020 then when they actually
start locking it down people will be
used to it
because they they thought it was already
happening well i'll tell you this look
man obviously that daily mail story was
wrong because it contradicted itself
which is why i always say talk to your
doctor about what's right for you you
know and there's another good reason too
because i got a feeling like whatever
ends up happening in the long run
people are going to come back and
they're going to be like tim said x or y
and i'm not going to be the person who's
going to be responsible for your health
decision so by all means you could be in
the comments right now saying tim is
dumb
i would appreciate it great because i
don't want anybody putting the
responsibility on me for your health
decisions yeah
nah sheamus you go talk to your doctor
that's i i have a bunch
a whole bunch for buddies james
conversations he was like i'm gonna do
everything
and i i i had a hidden camera when i was
talking to tim and i showed with my
doctor i was like how much can we get
from how much money can we get from this
guy
sheamus went to the vitamin and he's
like you should have talked to your life
talk to your lawyer about how much money
you're gonna get from tim paul
after you went into the kitchen where we
have all the vitamins and he just
grabbed like
c d a multivitamin he's just chugging
him and he's like it's healthy tim said
so and i'm like yeah
that's true so here's the interesting
thing though they say that um
that half of people let me let me see
exactly what they said they said
more than half of unvaccinated americans
believe that that they're more dangerous
than the virus itself well that makes
sense
here's well no so i'm gonna pull up the
story this is from uh
this is from upmc uh university of
pittsburgh and carnegie mellon
university researchers identify groups
hesitant about covet 19 vaccine this is
the most fascinating to me
the study says the largest decrease in
hesitancy between
january and may by education group was
in those with a high school education or
less
hesitancy held constant in the most
educated group
those with a phd by may phds were the
most
hesitant group while vaccine hesitancy
decreased across virtually all racial
groups
black and pacific islanders had the
largest decreases joining hispanics and
asians at having lower vaccine hesitancy
than whites in may
why i have no answer for that well the
data i mean if you listen to
you know peak prosperity chris martinson
if you're using a brett weinstein and
pierre course
that's wrong there's scientists that
just fish data and the data speaks for
itself no the
no no it literally doesn't we had chris
martinson on the show with all due
respect he's a very smart man he's got a
phd and i think
in toxicology and when we talked with
him he said here's 53 studies on
ivermectin and then i googled it and
found a whole bunch more saying the
exact opposite the data doesn't speak
for itself we'll have to go into it on
the after show there's some there's some
studies that i've seen that have just
been
mind-blowing bro we we literally i i
pulled up
studies and there's so there's studies
that say
these things these treatments do nothing
and there are studies saying they do
some things
none of these treatments are fda
approved the point is the data
does not speak for itself well i i
disagree i think this is why phds are
are among the most hesitant is because
it's data heavy
it's it comes down to the data i mean
you gotta you gotta look at what was
polio doing to people it was crippling
children
the data was showing that people were
little kids were like
losing their ability to walk permanently
that's like screaming data
we haven't seen that kind of data with
this i mean there's been a lot of
illness 600 and what are we at 620 000
dead
with that had died with covid and when
they phrase it of
covid that's that's kind of a
manipulation because
a lot of it is comorbid and people have
obesity and they die with like a heart
failure but they had coveted in their
system so it gets logged
kovit is like the uh the the he like you
know it covet pulls the pin out and then
the train goes off the rails you know
what i mean
so it's like people who may have
survived with comorbidities
don't when they get it's tough to say
it's that that's a situation where you
don't know what it would have been
without it because they didn't have it
what the data is saying well you don't
know if they hadn't gotten covered what
would have happened
because they had gotten i hear from
people all the time they're like hey i
read this about that this that or
otherwise and i'm like i'm going to read
that and then i find conflicting
information
from like legitimate sources and i'm
like i can't draw an honest conclusion
go talk to your doctor because i i
when chris martinson was here and he
said 53 studies i said great let's pull
them up and i pulled them up i'm like
that's really fascinating
and then i googled other studies to see
if there was a you know
a contradiction sure enough i found like
several many and i'm like i asked him
you know these studies say
the opposite he goes oh well that study
was bad i'm like how are you going to
come to me and tell me this study is
good this study is bad when they're both
studies okay i'm a layman
and and i can respect him because i
think he's a smart guy and he knows more
about it than i do
and i can respect brett weinstein but
then there are many other doctors that i
see writing stories who don't appear
overtly political who are saying the
inverse
i suppose it's just i've seen chris
martinson pierre corey
brett weinstein brett's not a doctor not
a virologist
he's a biologist biologist but he's a
very smart scientist you know pierre
corey is a virologist
is chris martin center viral but bro
what i'm telling you is if you only
watch
one thing and then say that must be true
the data doesn't speak for itself when
you can pull up contradictory
information
okay maybe maybe yeah you're right data
doesn't speak for itself but i did get
this from reputable sources that's the
reason i'm
and i got contradictory information from
reputable sources as well
which we pulled them up on the show here
we go right now on this
i remember touching on it i don't
remember like i literally did these
studies who paid these
people to do these studies you see
that's the problem when people say
well your organization is no good
because of this that
but yeah but your organization i'm like
dude that means literally nothing but
the problem is some organizations will
do studies
specifically to derive specific results
for political reasons people make
observations or determinations or trust
i
try my best to avoid doing that and so
that's what this is what guides
most of my work is that if i see some
conservative guy come out and say that
you know you got to buy your gold and
then the democrat guy comes out and says
you got to buy silver i'll be like well
we've got two contradictory people
giving contradictory advice
can i find source information to vet
which one is better hey i looked it up
gold's worth more
so when it comes to these studies you
see conflicting studies
do you just dismiss them all or do you
go deeper and try and figure out which
studies are right
or which ones are more accurate so the
issue is when you look at a study
what can you really determine about it
there's a doctor named dr john smith or
whatever his name is and i'm like okay
so i can look him up and then
i find a linkedin for a guy and i'm like
okay and i look up here's his university
and then i find a doctor jane doe and i
look her up and i'm like well they both
disagree with each other
i can't make a determination what am i
suppo so what am i supposed to
what am i supposed to tell people right
if there's conflicting information same
when they say buy gold buy silver you
have to kind of do
some deep research to figure out which
study is legit there are people who
want to believe one or the other and
they may have reason to
i'm not saying they're wrong i'm saying
i haven't been able to find anything
strong and so therein lies the big issue
it's why i don't definitively come out
and say you must do x or y i say
talk to someone you trust in the medical
field because when we have
when i see these things you know when i
talk to these like chris martinson he's
on the show twice now
i'm like i you know he i pulled up a
study
that he said was was was positive for
alternate treatments
and then i googled the study and found
another
paper that said the methodology was
flawed it was not a good study because
of these reasons
then i pulled up a study saying these
alternative treatments were ineffective
and he said to me oh but those studies
are flawed
because they're you know and i'm okay
dude right with all due respect so one
of those
those those things are ineffective
because we never tested them for
efficacy
they'll do that sometimes i'm saying i'm
saying we sat here we have the episode
it's on timcast.com
where i was like i can pull up something
saying literally what you just said in
the other direction they would say that
about aspartame they said there's no
evidence aspartame
has any links to cancer because we never
studied aspartame
that's like that's that's really
irrelevant to what we're talking about
that's medical logic i'm talking about
the i'm talking about fact-finding and
determining
you know to the best of our abilities
truth and you can argue that you trust
or don't trust a particular political
faction
or those who advocate for a certain
direction i don't think that's good
enough
i want proof now there's a good reason i
think not just the media
but we have a big issue now when the cdc
comes out and says here's a list of
things and i'm like okay well i do have
a personal bias against government for a
lot of reasons
but if i can't disprove it that puts me
in a difficult position so why do you
think
uh that it's mostly phd people that are
that's why i said i have
no answers it's hard to know also
because you don't know what their phds
are in
that's right it could be it could be
like i think who said this before was it
you were saying like it could be like
feminist dancing it could be like a phd
in lesbian poetry i have no idea
right so we have we have we have no idea
that's why i say it's interesting
but i'm seeing a lot of people highlight
that as if that's evidence of something
and i'm like it's just a group of people
maybe they're activists who hate donald
trump because they're in universities
and how many people was
pulled here was like 2 000 people you're
also you're so what you're
doing this is data from people who are
saying
that they were already against of
getting the vaccine
it's probably i mean it could very well
just be the case that if someone has a
phd their opinion was more likely to be
backed up with statistics again whether
they're ones you would agree with or
disagree with in the first place and so
that locks them into it more firmly
or they're more likely to be stodgy and
stubborn
exactly well and i think that plays into
it as well um
and that's exactly part of why i said
statistics whether you agree whether you
would agree with them or disagree with
them i think people with phds people
whose brains work more quickly
are more conventionally intelligent tend
to be a bit more prideful and they're
also better at convincing themselves of
things
here's here's what i'm saying to me a
phd is just a twitter check mark in real
life like
right i don't really trust it all that
much but here's here's what i'm saying
all the information we present you can
take into consideration however you see
fit
but i if i can't make a determination
i'm not going to make one
so i i need i need sources before i come
out and say something and you know
i get things wrong every so often or
jump the gun it happens i'm far from
perfect
but i try to avoid things if i can't
prove it your point about studies is
interesting because i feel like they do
this every other month with dietary
stuff
fats are bad fats are good use this oil
don't use this oil this is going to kill
you you're going to get cancer from
coffee coffee is good for your heart
coffee cures depression for women what
am i supposed to think
so i think that in the end really boils
down to one
individual rights and two common sense
and like i don't even know what to tell
you it's not like a whole read the
studies thing because
you're not gonna understand all thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you